perky
modern yet timeless
the mini has been a mainstay in the
sporty subcompact segment for decades
but even classic has to go with the
times at present there are seven
variants of bmw's little grocery getter
the latest version is a refinement of
the standard three-door model it's grown
a bit of course
together with germany's automobile
association adac we tested the five-door
mini cooper hatch
the ada sees klaus britta wonders if
comfort is given way to convenience
the typical go-kart feeling is still
noticeable in the five-door model owing
to the very direct and tight steering
and the stiff suspension
on long rides that results in a loss of
comfort
the engine sounds quite pithy but also a
bit loud in the interior
that's no wonder because the car is
powered by a 1.5 litre turbocharged
gasoline engine with only three
cylinders
100 kilowatts and a maximum torque of
some 220 newton meters is not a bad
rating for the little engine that could
the mini cooper sprints from 0 to 100
kilometers per hour in 8.2 seconds
swerving to avoid sudden obstacles at 90
kilometers per hour doesn't phase the
mini at all and neither does slamming on
the brakes at 100 kilometers per hour
the mini comes to a standstill after a
respectable 34 meters
small car small engine equals a small
bill at the pump that formula actually
works here
using the adac ecotest criteria the new
mini cooper consumes some 5.5 liters of
premium per 100 kilometers the
manufacturer had actually promised 4.7
the workmanship of the mini's interior
is flawless
the design is a bit playful yet lots of
soft plastic belies and effort at high
quality
passengers now have a lot more space in
the rear seat which thanks to the two
extra doors is easily accessible
the cargo area really is mini even for a
mini with a variable volume from 185 to
445 liters
the all-round visibility is excellent
important for city commutes
even with five doors the mini is an
attractive car that will certainly find
a fan base
though it's a little tight getting in
the two rear doors make day-to-day use
much more practical at twenty thousand
six hundred euros our test vehicle cost
just seven hundred euros more than the
three-door model
a worthy investment especially since
driving performance is on par with its
little brother